[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I am link and I am Rhett this week at
the roundtable of dim lighting you asked
us anything and we're gonna answer
anything we have everything that we
decided to answer we're gonna give you
everything in answer form but we have a
couple of little things to update you
about one hear an announcement season
ear biscuits is gonna continue through
the summer we also we're gonna have a
short three week break from GMM and we
come back with a good mythical summer
episode we also haven't talked about if
there's a near biscuits break it's like
we probably shouldn't be having all
these logistic conversations on the show
but it just suffice it to say we're
still figuring that out but no but I
actually was part of a conversation that
you weren't part of oh really er there
was definitely definite discussion about
your biscuits continuing through the
summer
well not that there won't be a break of
some kind I don't want to pry don't want
to talk us into anything you know me man
well you know me and you know what I'm
thinking let's make more business
decisions right here on the Internet in
front of everyone you know what let's
just let you make them hashtag ear
biscuits you make the decision for huts
and that in itself is a business
decision that you just made that day
well it was a joke oh well okay okay so
let's get to some of your questions Jen
s asks if you had to replace one room in
your current house with the same type of
room from your childhood home it could
be bathroom your bedroom etc and keep it
as it was back then same furniture
appliances cetera which room would you
replace and why nostalgia practicality
hashtag your biscuits great question Jen
this is like this is such an intricate
original question kudos to you and I
don't ever say kudos that might be the
first time I've ever used that when I
was not referring to the candy bar do
they still make that I don't know what a
good question the funny thing is is who
does the kudos if they're still making
kudos yeah it's such a specific
interesting question but it does
immediately cause me to think I mean I
haven't
suppose what's you okay what's your
answer well we have a guest bedroom in
my home in my current home yeah and it
is I've seen it it is I put my jacket on
the bed in this bedroom because that you
wake well when I come over there and
there's like friends over there and if
friends have coats or jackets you throw
your jacket on the bed that tends to be
the bed where the jackets go other
people's yeah I saw a whole pile of I'm
on that bed I've never seen it being
used for anything but that like it for I
guess I don't know how I should feel
about that I feel like I should have a
place for people to hang their coats I'm
just throw them on a bed yeah you're
messed up man you're messed up or you've
messed up I think I think this means you
personally are morally corrupt no I
actually think it's a good thing because
a guestroom unless you constantly have
guests which will be stupid and you're
not because you don't then it's a great
utilization of that room when guests
aren't there
well my cup holder my specific issue
with the room is that my wife was dead
set on having a guest room and I totally
get it and she's very hospitable much
more hospitable than me oh and we do
have the guest room is used quite often
obviously when relatives come into town
but sometimes if like we've got like a
friend who's over and it's really late
and they'll just be like can I just stay
in the guest bed and they they sleep in
the guest bed so that happens and I and
I really like that and I understand the
utility and also just the you know the
hospitality in that I thought you were
gonna say that you didn't like it
because then it meant you had to have
guests no I don't mind guests and it
also serves as the room that I sleep in
when things go sideways oh well no I
haven't when like when she's sick when
just sick quarantine room so she she's
been sick I'd say in the past three
years that we've been in this house I've
slept down there like four or five
nights when like just like a real bad
night she's like coffin or something
like that or if I'm really sick and I'm
trying to get away from her Wow some
reason she gets the nice bed and I go
down to the guest bed you kind of think
about that a little bit more but my
issue with it is that there's no there's
not a it's only used a very small
probably
single percentage amount of the time but
the coats even then you're still in an
eight nine percent of total usage of
this room right right and what I would
like it to be is I would like it to be
more like what we call the extra room in
my childhood home remember that oh yeah
you spent a lot of time in the extra
room the extra room was where me and you
like if you spent the night we stayed in
that room because it had the TV well
here's my recollection of the room see
if I'm right you go up the stairs and
instead of going then wrapping around to
go to either your room or your brother
Cole's room or then wrap around further
to the bathroom you hang a left at the
top of the stairs and there's this extra
room that then it had it had brown
carpet it had a brown couch that would
pull out into a bed it had a brown
television on a brown TV stand lots of
brown in your member that it had it had
a remote but it was like one of the
first night your television remotes it
that was made it had it was a remote
that had two buttons it had it had a
power button it had channel up channel
down and I can ball you got you a
picture of this remote it was huge it
was like a match box it's amazing okay
it's like it was a hide-a-key
first of all looking more like a huge
freaking key let me confirm and then
there was an exercise bike let me well
that was later but let me confirm a few
of the things and then I'm gonna point
out a few things that you got wrong so
interestingly you had the entire layout
of the house correct except you didn't
go left when you got to the stairs you
just went right or straight
it wasn't brown it was mustard yellow
carpet which I guess could be construed
to be brown well it was dirty it was oh
it was very old okay and I see it that
the couch was it was like that Chinese
takeout mustard color yeah yeah I mean
since you brown you know you could call
it brown the TV was not brown the TV
wasn't it was black and silver because
it was a Zenith yeah and the remote
wasn't also black and silver and the
remote was a brick was it the exact
dimensions of an actual
Rick and it had a power button that was
that what was hidden in this remote well
I know you're like why you guys talking
so much about this remote but I have to
tell you because I remember this remote
it had a power button incorrectly but it
left an impression if you looked at the
remote from the top it was all all
metallic on one side and then all black
on the other side and the black part was
where it had the buttons and it had a
power button which was beige and went
all the way across it was a big
horizontal like a space bar and then it
had a channel button and then it had
another horizontal button which I think
was the mute button you want to have a
really big power button so when your mom
comes up those stairs to see what you're
watching you can just you can scramble
and turn party in progress what had to
turn party and progress off and then it
had up and down volume but it was so
powerful I'm sure that it gave it I was
exposed to something that may manifest
itself as cancer later in my life
because it was such a powerful remote I
remember I used to take the thing and I
would put it underneath the couch and
then put pillows all around my hand the
test it you create an obstacle course
for the remote and then I would hit
channel up and it would change it's like
you cannot do that with the moderate it
was like red really like magic I don't
know how it worked and why don't they
still do that because just before that
there were television remotes I I didn't
own one but because they were too smart
for this it was a remote that was
connected by a wire cord like you have
like a 12 foot cord to the television
well could you I mean you might trip
somebody but at least you didn't have to
get up yeah that was the first remote
was just a and tethered to the box and
then I think when they had to remove
that tether with like whatever
technology they use the remotes got huge
and I slowly got smaller just like
phones but I would have that room in my
house now because it had a television in
it which is the one thing that I've
talked to a Jesse about was like we need
a room that the kids can go and watch
television in when they have their
friends over because our house is so
open that there's two TVs in two
different parts of the house but they
both their sound bleed and you know you
don't want to be able to make that room
like a playroom yeah because the door
they'll have a pull-out couch sure yeah
for guests and right we would get into
an argument about whether or not a
personal conversion good enough to sleep
on for guests but ok that's what that's
what I would do you don't want to stand
forever I put that room in that place
what would you do I would put my
childhood bedroom in the place of either
one of my boys bedrooms because I have
to play with your stuff my childhood
bedroom it did have a little television
but he didn't have as many sculling do
you want me to tell you what I remember
about your ok the bedroom before you
tell me what you do what was true about
it ok yeah now I'm not going all the way
back to the Jimmy house I'm going to
write to this from fourth grade fourth
grade house until college because I
don't actually don't remember much about
that first house me neither actually
well I I do but you walked into the
house ironically I recreated that the my
bedroom at what must must when mom was
married to Jimmy that bedroom from like
kindergarten to third grade I basically
recreated that in my current in what
you're about to describe my second
fourth grade bedroom it's like a lot of
the same decor okay same furniture I
mean we just moved everything and then I
like reconfigured it you walked into the
house through the carport you took a
left and then there was a door to a
guest bathroom and then you would walk
through the guest bathroom too on the
other side of the door the other door
then you come into your room you could
also come in the front door and straight
into the living room then take an
immediate right and go into your bedroom
so you had two entries to your bedroom
which I always thought was very cool
because I didn't have that
know your exit you know yeah I'd want
you know I had one end and one out yeah
and there so let's say I'm walking into
the I'm walking out of the bathroom and
then there's the your bed on the left
centered in the wall you've got a
bedside table with a Garfield phone I
that because it's also there's a picture
of it in the book of mythicality but
then right at the foot of the bed there
is a dresser with a television on it
yeah and then the closet is on the right
side we have a Foley bi-fold doors
closet and I remember you had a wooden
bed that had wooden balls on top of the
post that I would play with and take off
yeah you could up the bed you could
twist them off at an NC State bedspread
no you didn't get NC state pillow no I
had an NC State trashcan trashcan with
one of those basketball hoop things on
the trashcan that you'd throw your trash
and like make it through the hoop and we
also we had that in our office for a
long time same trash can yep that's
right I don't know how that got moved
there but as a grown adult we have my
childhood trash can in my office
but you would put this in your in your
home now there's a small bedroom yeah
the one thing you forgot is I had a my
stepdad Jimmy made a bench that the that
the seat hinged open and it was a toy
box Oh at the foot of the bed
no at the side of the bed I'm in between
the two windows that were the front of
the house yeah yeah yeah
and I had a freaking toy box in my
bedroom until I went to college yeah I
had a lot about that from time to time I
had a bulletin board on my wall that had
like a bunch of knickknacks and from
like art that I made in middle school
and I just kept a kid I kept
accumulating all the way through high
school I mean my room aged me down for
many years it looked like a little boy's
room and really you became a man and
it's still lit like a little boy's room
right nothing to be ashamed of fun fact
yeah you don't have that room anymore
you got going to Lando's room right now
you can screw off the top of the the
bedpost you do that from time to time
for old times sake no but the reason why
you can do it is because it is that bit
it's the same bed it's my bed land I was
telling I was like Lander you know what
this
I slept in his bed my entire life
literally I did not know that you had
that Bennett yes we painted white
because we put it in Lily's room when
she was a baby
yeah and Christy wanted me to paint it
white and now it's been it's been white
ever since but it's in Lando's room and
it's um it's that same one I have a
white bed in my bedroom it's like I
sleep in a big princess bed yeah maybe
you want to swap it out but there's but
there's not a lot of technology in there
it's just a lot of nostalgia so I'd like
to go into one of my kids bedrooms and
like step back into my childhood and not
have as it wouldn't have as many screens
to worry about right that one kid would
be a little bit advantaged and
disadvantaged all at the same time yeah
you start having girlfriends you have to
talk to her on a Garfield phone that's
healthy man okay we're gonna get to more
your questions in just a second but
first we're gonna take a short break to
let you know that you can get the shirts
that we're wearing and the mugs that
we're drinking out of add a little ol
place called mythical dot store mm-hmm
get these boil for safety mugs while
supplies last because they are on their
way out if you want one you better scoop
it up and you know what I just put it to
my lips right now that's nostalgia well
the funny thing about this is the boil
for safety the reason that we made these
mugs in the first place is because
oftentimes in the old school GMM when we
were eating something it had just been
boiled for safety because we didn't have
anybody who knew how to make anything
and chase would end up doing a lot of
the cooking and he would just boil
things for safety so we wouldn't die
thankfully we've got some qualified
people to make food for us at this point
so but I still boil some stuff every
once in a while some things are boiled
for safety but this is this kind of
represents a moment in gmm history and
it's represented by this cup this mug
that will go away soon so mythical dot
store also check out our amazon store
what's that URL I always forget
amazon.com slash mythical that's it
thank you for supporting internet
teaming okay here's another question
from Morgan another Morgan who worked
for not Morgan Morgan this is Morgan are
not I mean yeah I can say her name she's
not asking an embarrassing question
Morgan Rowling okay is there something
you have done or said in publically
distributed into
t GMM or biscuits an interview etc that
you regret yes
do we regret anything that we've put out
there on the Internet
well yes I mean I could think of a very
recent example well okay I know I know
shoot what you think it I was also
thinking we and maybe we talked about
this I think we talked about this in a
live AMA somewhere maybe it was that in
the QA after a tour mythicality stop
where someone asked us why they can't
watch the guacamole song anymore and
it's because we made made it private
because we just didn't think that it was
it was it was it comes across as
culturally insensitive the the way that
we portrayed ourselves and the
characters we played in the guacamole
song so yeah it was worth much more to
be respectful than it was to keep an old
video up there yeah a lot of people
asked about that one we've changed and
the world has changed quite a bit and
looking back over ten years of that
video it was like ooh this is uh and I
think that's a good thing this strikes
differently than it did back then but
the most recent example that I'm
thinking about is the international food
taste test
the most recent dart food taste test on
GMM we're linked brought in the
professional darkness the actual origins
of dishes that you thought were from one
place but they're actually from another
and one of those was chicken Kiev and we
were and we in our ignorance we're just
like well obviously this is from Russia
which is the capital of Ukraine
so it's funny things like this you know
but you didn't what even what you said
didn't wasn't right you said Russia was
the capital at Ukraine I said Kiev which
is the capital L crane I didn't hear you
in Ukraine is very contentiously not
Russia right that's what the whole
controversy is about so now this is one
of those things that like what's the
best way to address this because what I
will say is that yes
now that
I think about it and when Stevie pointed
it out in the video in a moment it was a
oh yeah right a minute later in the
video were like oh that was a big
mistake and we left all that in the edit
but which I'll come back to in a minute
but what you see in the comments and
this is just a very common thing is that
the moment you make the ignorant
misinformed insensitive comment that we
made are not comment but statement that
we made about Kiev being in Russia and
being incorrect that's when people who
take this personally who know about the
situation and take it personally and are
offended that's when they begin to
comment a minute later they've already
hit Send on their comment and now they
see that we actually say oh crap we're
gonna piss people off when we said that
and a couple people did say oh I'm sorry
I made this comment before I saw that
you guys corrected yourself or whatever
but I would say I definitely regret that
but at the same time it is not the first
or the last time that we're gonna say
something that is ignorant and sensitive
misinformed can be construed and
misunderstood and will offend people
because it is the nature of the way that
we make our show and we do our stuff
yeah you know what it's funny because I
was actually thinking about the way that
we make our show this morning I don't I
don't know what got me to thinking about
it but I was appreciating the fact that
you know very early on we decided that
we weren't gonna make we weren't gonna
make good mythical morning that jump-cut
show we're gonna make it have a lot of
cuts we're gonna we were going to you
know we're gonna move at speed a
conversation and the Edit was gonna
reflect that that it was going to be
very minimal or not at all as production
is increasing we're doing more things
physically it requires us to like stop
down and like bring stuff in it set
stuff up that it's just plain boring but
in terms of conversation and what
happens I think we're I really am glad
that we made that decision because I
think a hallmark of the show I guess I
don't think about it that often I was
just thinking about it this morning was
that
some of the best part parts of the show
are those just honest moments of
something happening that there's not a
lot of internet content out there where
you see unexpected things happen as a
cornerstone of any other property you
know I think you know if I am to talk
about like a daily vlogger or somebody
who's just catching everything and then
they're making a calculated editorial
decision to show you something that was
spontaneous but it's being packaged you
know it's like it's being you know you
got a vlogger who the classic I'm
vlogging and then something makes a
noise and it distracts the person so
then they make a funny comment about it
and then they get back to their thing
well and and and they include that in
the in the jump cut to give you kind of
a behind-the-scenes view on like
remember how I'm making this vlog you
know things are happening or I'm messing
up and for comedic effect I can add
these things in or just for a level of
sincerity or whatever right but I think
our show thrives on the fact that those
things that we mess up or something goes
sideways and then that's the thing that
we walk away like yes something
something happened we were surprised a
surprise we're surprised we you know
know but I've said before the things
that my favorite parts my favorite shows
are in in moments within shows are the
moments when we make each other laugh
based on something that was just
accidental or unexpected right but but
it's not just that it's not just the
funny stuff it's just that okay this is
what we plan to do and it's pretty alive
you know it has this feel that I'm I'm
proud of our show that it that it is
that we I didn't know it was gonna work
this way but that it's kinda like okay
let's see what happens yeah because the
show that as a viewer and as us we're
all seeing what's gonna happen because
the show is not scripted you know we
talked before about
we talked about kind of like the the
changes with genome 22 people felt like
things felt more scripted even though we
were basically doing things the way we
had done them the big we have parts of
the show that are scripted like the very
beginning of the show or when we're
setting up an item that we're bringing
in or setting up like how a game works
just so we don't get bogged down you
because we don't want to waste your time
with a bunch of details that we're just
figuring out off the top of our heads
but then once we set up a structure and
it's just basically anything goes at
that point and the funny thing is is it
this is an interesting middle ground
right because you've got live streamers
which we all know the infamous examples
of people getting in trouble for saying
things on a live stream now here's what
I will say is that there are a number of
things that we've said on good mythical
morning that we had to edit out because
we were like yeah and you know yep well
I won't cut you off go ahead the way
that that came across again this is none
of this stuff would be like oh I can't
believe they said that but it's the kind
of things that we know how the Internet
responds to things and it was something
was said in the moment or somebody made
a joke and they didn't realize oh that I
didn't mean to make that joke but we end
up crossing the line in saying some
things sometimes and then the crew will
be will laugh and we'll all know okay
well that can't go in the edit that's
the nature of just doing something off
the cuff and that's maybe happened a
handful of times even on your biscuit
but it's not nearly the level of because
we do have the option to edit things out
but when it comes to something like the
chicken Kiev screw up that we made I
think we usually what happens is if we
say something and we're like mmm
I could see how that could be taken the
wrong way I didn't mean it for it to
come across like that so at the end of
an episode we'll say
hey Stevie hey Darren list let's take
that out and sometimes they just make
the call to do that on their own or the
editor makes their call to do that if
they think that there's something that
could be taken the wrong way but that
chicken Kiev moment wasn't one of them
right and I'm not saying it was some
huge controversy and we've like lost I
mean there was one person who said
you've lost a fan they were because and
listen I understand
don't understand but I appreciate how
sensitive and a bit of an issue the
whole Ukraine thing is and so it's like
- for us - in our American ignorant you
know right we have the privilege of
being ignorant about so many other areas
in the world and it's the thing that
would come across as arrogant and
insensitive to me if I was not in the
United States so I completely understand
it you know were the only people in the
world that only speak one language you
know we can get by we just speaking
English so there's there's roots easy to
hate it's easy to hate Americans and so
I totally get that and when we say
something like that it seems like we're
just completely missing the boat but we
didn't really understand how sensitive
it would be to some people some people
would respond to it so in retrospect
would have taken it out but it's an
example of one of those things that I
regret saying that you know I also
regret not just saying it but regret
that you ended up hearing it do you
regret talking about it right now
probably Coral da Dalzell asks what was
it like when your first kids were born
working in maternity has me see a wide
variety of Dada reactions to the
birthing process and I was wondering
what yours were we know each other's who
should go first based on that knowledge
I mean my eye yours is probably funnier
than mine oh no I got to be funny well
I'm just saying that I thought you well
but you but you had a different you
didn't your wife wasn't just go ahead
then I don't I can't make any guarantees
that's how funny I'm gonna be but well
my um Locke's birth was relatively
uneventful 14 years ago it's hard to
remember fort I just remember that you
know jesse was dead-set
we were not about the natural birthing
she was dead set on all the drugs and
all the injections that would make it an
easy process she she made that decision
without shame from all the women who
told her that she needed to go into a
river and just poop the bay
be out into the creek she was like no
creep poop baby Creek so good for you
ladies who make that decision but that
was not the decision that my wife and I
made and it was not my decision it was
her decision and I was fully supportive
of it so she she basically had some
difficulty with the labor but then she
took the drugs and had the epidural
injection and I went to sleep on a couch
and then I remember he woke up and a
baby was there no no no I remember being
awakened by a nurse who said get ready
you're about to become a father
oh and I got stood up that's a rude
awakening in there and I'd say within 20
minutes we had a baby and relatively
uneventful pull or on anything or cut
anything I don't remember I don't think
did you like hold an ankle
I wouldn't no no I actually I stayed
back a small distance like when you see
you know like when you see like a
scuffle at an Arby's but you know what
I'm saying
Garvey's gonna have a scuffle and you're
like that's curly fries I get you hot I
don't know if I should get involved in
this I'm a big guy I could probably get
in there and restrain somebody how could
you even say that are you accessing a
memory I've been in I mean I've watched
a lot of internet videos I've seen many
a scuffle in them you like Arby's you
like Google RB scuffle everybody do the
Arby's come off there's so many ways we
could take that RB scuffle calm it's a
place where you either learn how to
dance or you to see a bunch of videos of
people fighting in it are we are we
shuffle no no the Arby's scuffle is a
dance it looks like you're fighting
there's two people fighting no they're
dancing it's a two person thing cuz
there's only so many like tight curly
fries to go around then everybody else
is left with just a c-shaped curly fries
yeah you don't want that but what if I
want c-shaped fries I'm gonna order C
fries but you can put if I want curly
fries if I order curly fries I expect
them all to be curly but you can put you
can put a C fry into your nose like a
bull right but that's fine and good rep
but
then the menu should say blood rise like
bullnose fries with a cute Curt a few
curly went pigtails thrown in
I don't cuz that's what it is I think
you're asking too much of Arby's so
you're I stood at a safe distance and no
one consulted me I'm not the best how do
you think the baby should come out at
this point sir I'm not the best in in
birth and death situations like the
beginning and the ending of life is not
where you go to the register for comfort
or like words of wisdom you kind of just
go to me for like safe distance slightly
concerned stairs yeah you become like
human wallpaper yeah I like I don't know
what to say to people who are going
through hard things I'm actually
learning I am I am learning about how to
connect more with this part of my my
humanity and yet this part of my yeah
I'm really working on Mike's you should
be a doula I was pointing to my heart by
the way for those of you who listen to
your biscuits bless you for that I think
you should you should
well alright just we'll put up let's put
a pin in the doula thing yeah so
ultimately it was pretty uneventful I
did not offer a lot I don't think I
looked engaged enough for anyone to ask
me anything like sir do you want to come
in and cut something okay so I didn't
say anything I just remember they put
lock in like a little incubator said you
would not not incubator but the little
because he was a tub it's a tough it's
like a warming thing but it's not for
preemies it's just we're all babies go
yeah it's like that's it's like it
Arby's where they put the fries under
there yes just like Arby's the hospital
is like Arby's right and I think of it
because I visited maybe it wasn't it was
in RVs that explains a lot that's why I
never got a bill but the and I just kind
of like that's when I began to talk to
him it's sort of like came out of the
shell and became a father
yeah Shepherd on the other hand but the
different different story I'll tell it
another time in the past you've added a
part to that story which you left out
which was like like there
there's like there was like multiple
layers to the birth and you decided to
leave that part out
that's Shepards birth oh you talk about
the the screaming and the yeah you got
it yeah I just might as well tell I
right I hear it well I I mean I want to
hear your story but I'll tell it I'll
tell the quick version we thought we
were gonna do exactly the same thing
with Shepherd you know take the drugs
get the epidural but what happened was
when Jesse got to the doc what had
happened was what had happened was is we
got to the doctor and they like tested
her you know checked on the dilation
situation and they were like oh you
might as well just go back home
but then jesse was like I don't think so
I think I'm having this baby right now
and then another doctor came in and said
you are having the baby right now and we
don't have time for any of the things
that we planned they the nurse person
must have been measuring in the wrong
spot I think they were using a curly fry
instead of a finger but the so I the
dilation of your I don't know how many
different things you can measure the
dilation of but three curls of a curly
gotta get that she's great pearls right
so the doctor that was supposed to
deliver the baby was currently in the
shower at home and so an another doctor
it might have been a janitor I don't
know it was just a dude with a coat on
he he delivered the baby stranger to you
but she did it completely naturally
going against all her best intentions
and she screamed so loudly that I was
like embarrassed you know I'm saying I'm
also easily kind of embarrassed in
situations like they like social
situations so all in the same she's like
a voice major was this like a operatic
crack the glass or in a situation
nothing beautiful about it at all it was
blood-curdling and it was it's the way I
described it later was it was as if she
was about to be in a head-on collision
and she knew it
and she was screaming that way and then
it kept happening over and over again
Oh hellas situation but again I was more
embarrassed every empathetic every
contraction it
wasn't just the last moment no that went
on for uh well it's but by the time from
the time she said this baby is coming to
the doctor saying this baby is coming
he was like twelve minutes or something
and Shepard was was there and that
really just basically was indict you
were embarrassed he was going to be like
for people's life people like look at
you and you were like uh I do not know
this woman yeah it's like I isn't this
gonna make the hospital look bad like at
women like this screen here close the
window is being an Arby's right now but
okay well you know I'm not great with
blood flow yeah but you talk about
circulation and I get queasy I knew I
had to be seated for the birth of lily
and its subsequent to but they induced
Christy and twelve hours later you know
they give you this magic pitocin stuff
and you're in it makes you have a baby
that's how babies are made it's called
pitocin and it didn't work so at some
point they're like monitoring all the
all these vitals of everybody involved
not me
I'm not really involved at this point
and there you know they had to make an
executive decision to for her to be
rushed into a c-section they cut you
open like a watermelon and pull out
another little bit smaller watermelon
yep that's done and as as anxious as I
was about being party to a vaginal
delivery a bit yeah I've been waiting to
use that terminology I was much more
scared when we were walking into an
emergency I'm not an operating room and
I'm like getting scrubbed up right and
then I honestly I've told this story
before
and it would help me remember it by
listening back to that but I don't know
where I've told it but it was so I don't
know if this was the first or not but
because once you have one c-section she
Lily Christy ended up having three one
for every child it's very very dangerous
to
have a VBAC they call it a VBAC after
you've had vaginal birth after c-section
be back
oh no that's the whole thing okay yeah
all it's an acronym for the whole
situation yeah it is because you know my
sister-in-law she did it did that and it
was yeah I don't want to say she almost
died but she maybe maybe she almost died
well and my layman's understanding of it
is once you have a healed c-section scar
and you're trying to have a normal birth
like all of that pressure and pushing
could just you could just explode like a
like a Arby's roast beef filled balloon
okay
and we Lord knows we didn't want that to
happen but with the first minutes like
oh man we we didn't talk too much about
c-section is happening she's in the
morning room for beef and cheddar I'm
out I'm outside putting on my scrubs and
they they forget about me of course and
they're like you're not important
they're going about their business and
then they and I'm getting worried I'm
like oh crap they're not coming out
you're not I'm not in there I'm gonna
miss this thing and I didn't have
anybody to talk to
and then finally a nurse it's like get
it get in here get in here you [ __ ] the
doctor knew that I was queasy about the
whole thing they put a curtain up and
I'm I'm up at by Christy's face and then
at the and then below the curtain
they're making like operational
incisions and stuff or one major one
it's a really these days it's super
small for what they do and we I had such
a rapport with the doctor and he knew
that I was queasy but then it and like I
was hiding behind this curtain like
trying to be supportive to Christy but
I'm not I'm not fascinated about what's
happening on the other down there right
I don't I'm there I don't watch footage
of any type of surgery like I'm not
crazy or weird well I'm thankful I'm
thankful for crazy and weird people
because that I am to measure the doctors
yeah and yeah by my definition and then
but then he was like they were working
on it for a while and all of a sudden he
starts yelling at me and he's like
Lync stand up and watch the miracle of
your baby being born this is this is
amazing you stand up and you watch this
happen
Wow and and again he was you know he was
we were very friendly like in all that
we got to know him very well this was
not a janitor like you had and so he had
earned the right to speak to me that way
and I respected the fact that he did
that and then I like so I'm like slowly
like standing up and then like I see him
freaking pull of human out of a big cut
and my wife but then your eyes are drawn
to the human and not to the cut and it
was in it was and they take him take her
over that way and then it's like you
know and I was okay but it but I was I
was scared he was a lot man I really
went through a lot I did but I did great
you did I was a champ yeah and I was
also very anxious about should i film
this and when should I be filming and
yeah yeah yeah yeah nobody tells you you
know I will mean I would have hired
somebody to do all I stopped filming I
don't think it didn't seem right no one
had told me to but I stopped filming
pretty early it didn't seem right to be
filming that thing the process I mean
yeah you got a baby why do you need
footage I got some footage of her of
Lily and like wouldn't there you know
like right when she's first starts
crying and stuff like that that's cool I
did pretty good I'm pretty proud of
myself I didn't faint it's not like when
I got cut by the Barbie or the knife
opening the Barbie there's another story
I've told but this is an interesting one
Kelly took a well that took a while but
you know what it was worth it
yeah totally worth it Kelly Jane Harman
how do you put on your shoes do you go
sock sock shoe shoe or sock shoes socks
you does anyone go sock shoe socks you I
did very recently what yeah
I thought it's so weird that she asked
this question because
why III go socks socks shoe shoe
normally but I now was thinking about
the specific cuz you know me a man of
procedure I literally was thinking about
this just like so kudos Kelly what I
what had happened what what had happened
was I had gotten these new shoes you
know the I got these boots here and I'm
wearing well not these but I had they
were like this and I was really excited
I'm like breaking them in I'm like
trying them out I got up the next
morning after wearing these shoes home
and breaking them in and I'm I was so
excited when I was putting on my shoes
to come into work that I put on one sock
and then I couldn't wait to put on the
shoe
I was I was literally so excited to put
on the shoe that I put it on before I
put on the other side how does that make
you feel great you know you got to have
something to get you through the day and
and that day yesterday I think it was it
was getting my shoe on as soon as
possible but you don't plan on repeating
this no once this is it only a new
director yeah only with new shoes do
what I do from it because you know
better than I do but from an efficiency
standpoint sock sock shoe shoe is
definitely the most efficient yeah I
think they're equally as efficient the
in terms of time it should be the same I
don't know I don't think so because I
think I think what first of all when you
get into a mode and a rhythm of a
repeated motion even just one repetition
you do the second one a little bit
faster but when it's back-to-back but
also you you you've got focus on the
socks and you've got two socks in your
hands and if you're like me you hold the
other sock while you put the other one
sock on well that's you know what that's
slick man you hold that sock in like
this part of your palm and then as soon
as you get through with the left sock
and I go left sock first I move over to
I like unfold it almost in one motion
Wow
and then go to the right sock it's just
I mean it's just something I've learned
over time so there's no way that sock
shoes socks you can be faster than that
but along those same lines so I got
these you know not a sponsor or Clark's
desert boots
because that's what Anthony Bourdain
wears everywhere and I'm like he travels
the world he's cool and I got them and
I'm like breaking them in wearing them a
lot and a lot of people are like if
you're gonna be doing a lot of walking
it could be good to get insoles and so I
got like some dr. Scholl's insoles to
put on top of the insoles of the boots
because they're kind of thin that's
always a good sign of a good pair of
shoes when you got to buy something else
to go in them to make them workable but
last night I've been talking a lot about
being naked lately but I'll just
continue
last night I was naked in my bedroom
except the boots and and I and it was
like it was like midnight 30 and I was
still up and I am like I gotta cut these
insoles to fit the shoes and I want and
I was anxious just like you want you
know putting the shoe on before the sock
I got to do this right now and so I'm
sitting there I'm put on the shoes I cut
the I put on the socks I cut the insoles
I put them on and then I I sit there I'm
in my boots
and then I just stand up man I didn't
know my wife was still awake I'm sitting
there naked except for boots on in my
bedroom and she and I hear her say I
should take a picture of this because
I'm gonna sit under standing there naked
in boots I was like Internet and I said
you know what maybe this is the moment
maybe this is when I just post my naked
nude this is when I post my nudes I mean
where would you post them Instagram
Rhett MC out also but it would be taken
down very quickly so I do it on Twitter
where it would not be taken down so read
MC on Twitter you want to see you the
nudes me in Boots and nothing else I
don't mean to box I did have socks and
insults dr. Scholl's also not a sponsor
but I'm gelling and they feel real good
right now I don't mean to burst your
bubble but hmm you with that last story
and especially with the plug you have
brought this on yourself
of course when you are talking about
these desert boots which I've had and I
warned you about I was like I had those
a couple of years back and they're not
that great bin was there for this
conversation Ben comes to work the next
day and he's talking to me about how
we're gonna approach shooting some of
the stuff you're not there he's like hey
don't tell read this but you know how
he's talking about how Anthony Bourdain
like wears those boots everywhere and
it's what he swears by and he wears him
all the time and they're his travel
boots it's like well I was watching some
Anthony Bourdain you didn't have and he
said the opening scene of the episode
that I happened to watch started on a
close-up of Anthony Bourdain's boots and
they were cowboy boots and then it pans
it tilts up his body okay and then he
says and then there's a voiceover from
Anthony Bourdain and he says for as far
back as I can remember I've worn these
cowboy boots everywhere that's not true
though that's what been told me and he
felt it he was like don't tell red
because he was so excited about these
boots well no no no no no I said I mean
I'm just saying that's what he said look
and you know what don't tell Ben that I
told you because he told me not to tell
you no no no I found a picture of
Anthony Bourdain with cowboy boots on
when I did the research I saw it in an
article and then I said look at all the
pictures and I saw that he had these
boots on lots of different places and
then separately somebody who works here
was like oh that's what Anthony Bourdain
wears all the time and I was like yeah
that's why I got him oh but he but I
have seen other pictures he he he does
have cowboy boots when he did a cowboy
ish thing somewhere on a ranch or
whatever he had a cowboy boots anyway
you know I'm not saying again I could be
wearing tennis shoes but you know you
know what the other thing Anthony
Bourdain doesn't have to have worn those
shoes for you to just read that he wears
them so that then you'll have an excuse
to buy do you know
I looked up before I looked up Anthony
Bourdain you know what I was trying to
figure out what they where uh who's that
host to double-dare that then got his
own like how it's made Marc summers yeah
I don't care what kind of he wears
loafers who's the guy who hosted a
family feud after it homes
yeah it's dead was it him no who's the
guy who invented Arby's was it him
mr. RB was it him no cowboy it is the
guy Oh Jack and Finn Harries oh yeah
they're all over the place all the time
they're like the coolest most
adventurous most you know ecologically
minded youtubers on the face of the
planet and good guys - we met a man yeah
nice and a few years ago
those guys have always been like way
ahead of the curve you know super smart
and like kind of like you always get the
feeling that they kind of like if they
look at the the business the-the-the the
business of YouTube and the chasing the
fame and stuff and they just kind of
just moved out of that Lane and said
they just wanted to go do what they
wanted to do one of them went to school
and one of them travels the world and
they both travel the world anyway they
got great instagrams even better than
read em see then I gotta say their
instagrams are even better than read em
see of course you're not gonna mention
jack harries and finn harries i don't
know what the okay but they're like the
epitome of like travel cool
and so i was like they got accents - I
wonder what boots they wear oh and so I
did I gotta say I did a lot of like
pinching and zooming on Jack and Finn's
boots as they traveled the world to try
to figure out what they wore and the
problem is is that one of them were the
Chelsea boot quite a bit which is the
one without laces and I just don't think
that that looks good on me I you know
the one that had like the elastic on the
side yeah you wouldn't wear those no but
they made it long gates the foot but
they make it look so cool I like
something that shortens the foot maybe
it's just because I'm a big guy I don't
know it but they make it look cool so
then I was like they both wear who's an
older taller slightly
less cool but still cool guy man theny
Bourdain and that's how I got to Anthony
Bourdain enough how I got to the desert
boots you see my process you see the
things I do with my time I think we see
your soul my psychosis yeah okay yes no
you want to save these other questions
for another time
absolutely I think we you know certainly
again we will prompt more questions and
we will there's a few of these we didn't
get through that will we'll sit on a
little bit we'll get back to and maybe
next month I think we'll do one of these
about every month or so
yeah continue yeah so we'd love your
feedback again we won't necessarily take
it but we would we would love it and now
we will take it we will take it into
consideration but what we're doing right
now with your biscuits that we're
playing around with is we're we're doing
these AMAs on a regular basis we're also
working in a rabbit hole and we're
working in a couple of more focused
questions whether that be about you know
it's about some subject travel parenting
whatever let us know what you're
thinking which ones you're really
enjoying so we can continue to make your
biscuits that you'd like to put in your
ears
simple as that will speak at you again
next week thanks for being here
[Music]